I'm YB and today we're doing a magnum
elmerita challenge they sent out an
email at work who wants to do it and all
my co-workers nominated me and so here I
am
I have Carlos I'm gonna be making the
Manuel special burrito it's our biggest
burrito here at Oh Pepe och so my
grandfather Manuel came up with it what
the story is is that cal state when it
had a football team a long time ago they
wanted a really big burrito for the full
players and he had nothing on the menu
so what happened was he went to the back
he said no a couple was something real
quick so you came up with this for you
to the mango special and depend on the
menu ever since this is the size of a
baby okay just gonna start from the
corner
it doesn't even wrap around the whole
thing
not gonna be a classy eating um get this
giant bite it's really good so it has a
lot of rice they put three scoops of
rice in it and rice is usually what
makes you pull first that's going to be
the challenge
[Music]
what's kind of like 1/3 I'm thinking if
I should take a break but if I do I make
it fuller I don't move I'm like almost
halfway definitely getting harder in the
beginning I was just like eating it
really fast and I'm like slowing down a
bit I feel a really gross right now I
just can't take more cheese right so
we're gonna switch over to my coworker
Kim and to finished up her info now that
I'm sitting down it's way bigger than I
initially thought
I didn't lunch so this is fine this will
be my lunch I think what I'm gonna do is
like I'm gonna work by sections at this
point we just want to finish it
my hand is like refusing to go to my
mouth so we have 10 minutes left I think
other than you to tap out it looks so
much bigger like one's ear on top of it
but I only have like 8 minutes I eat
rice pork and walk like on the regular
so
[Music]
trying to imagine that I'm really hungry
[Music]
so we're all dying right now yeah I
don't feel like a winner but when
finished yeah we
[Music]